and in a surprise development President
Barack Obama was awarded the 2009 this
just in in a surprise development
President Barack Obama has just been
given a Royal Geographic Society award
for discovering eight new states I've
now been in 57 states I think one left
to go in a breaking story President
Barack Obama has just unanimously won
the NBA's most valuable player award for
the 2010-2011 season
[Applause]
we interrupt this report with new Zepa
rock obama has just received a Tony
Award for Best spoken word performance
by a lead actor Barack Obama has been
given the Heisman Trophy for his
leadership on talking about the
possibility of a conceivable college
football playoff system I don't know any
serious fan of college football
who has disagreed with
President Barack Obama has just been
given the 2010 Nobel Peace Prize for
adding troops in Afghanistan I've called
for at least two additional combat
brigades to support our efforts there
and in other news the u.s. federal
budget for fiscal year 2009 totaled 1.4
trillion dollars tripling the previous
record which had been set in 2008
[Music]